[Music]
gravity it controls the universe
everything attracts everything else
including you Wow
in this final lesson we'll explore what
gravity means for space-time or rather
what space-time means for gravity until
now we've been dealing with things
moving at constant speeds with straight
world lines in space-time but once you
add gravity if you measure a speed at
one moment then again a bit later the
speed may have changed in other words as
I discovered gravity causes acceleration
so we need the world line to look
different from one moment to the next as
we saw in the last lesson the correct
way to tilt an object's world line is
using a Lorentz transformation Einsteins
stretch and squash trick so to map out
what gravity is doing to Toms motion we
need to create a whole load of little
patches of space-time each transformed
by different amounts so that my world
line is at a different angle in each one
and then we're ready to stitch
everything together we assemble a closi
quilt of space-time where world lines
look curved where the world lines join
the objects collide by making these
connections between the patches a
curvature gets built into space-time
itself but einstein's true genius was to
describe precisely how each patch is
stretched and squashed
according to nearby mass and energy the
mere presence of stuff curves the
space-time and curving space-time moves
the stuff around this is gravity
according to Einstein previously Isaac
Newton explained gravity using the ideas
of force and acceleration without any
wibbly-wobbly space-time and that did
pretty well but Einstein's theory does
just slightly better at predicting for
example the orbit of mercury around the
Sun or the way that light rays are
deflected by massive objects more
importantly Einstein's theory predicts
things but simply don't exist in older
theories where space time and gravity
were separate the stitching can
leave wrinkles in the space-time
material these are called gravitational
waves which should be detectable this
tiny repetitive subtle squashes and
stretches in space so we're building
experiments to check if they are there
in the meantime indirect evidence most
recently in the polarization patterns of
light left over from the Big Bang
strongly suggest that they are but
despite unstyled successes when too much
stuff gets concentrated into smaller
space like in a black hole the curvature
of space-time becomes so large there is
equations collapse we need a new picture
of space-time that incorporates quantum
mechanics to unlock the secret at the
heart of black holes which means there's
plenty more to be discovered about
space-time and space-time in the future
[Music]